if you've ever watched chris cuomo over
on cnn you may have wondered
how'd this guy get a tv show sure he's
got well-defined abdominal muscles and
good for him
but he can barely speak english there
are nights when cuomo emits
entire paragraphs that mean nothing at
all just pure gibberish
like pig latin or dogs barking it's kind
of remarkable
was this guy educated in the united
states let's check wikipedia
wait a second the entry says that chris
cuomo went to
yale university in connecticut that
can't be right
yale has famously high admission
standards your kids couldn't get into
yale no
chance they'd have to be incredibly
smart geniuses really
is chris cuomo a secret genius does he
have some amazing talent that's
invisible on television maybe he speaks
false urdu
maybe he has a deep grounding in
particle physics
perhaps he can calculate pi to the final
digit
actually no chris cuomo can't do any of
that
it turns out he has an even more
impressive qualification
his father was the governor of new york
if you want to get into a top american
college
it's best to have a parent who's a
well-known democratic politician
that's the most effective credential of
all and don't take our word for it
ask dante de blasio the son of bill de
blasio the incompetent mayor of new york
city
there's no evidence that the younger de
blasio did remarkably well in high
school
and yet like chris cuomo he somehow got
into yale
once there dante de blasio found himself
surrounded by people just like himself
the thoroughly average children of other
prominent liberals
according to press reports that would
include the offspring of at least
three democrats currently serving in the
u.s senate
michael bennett amy klobuchar and
sheldon whitehouse
all of them sent kids to yale did you
no but they did their colleague richard
blumenthal of connecticut meanwhile is
one of a stunning number of senate
democrats
who have sent children to harvard
university senator bob menendez of new
jersey is a harvard parent
so is senate minority leader chuck
schumer schumer sent both his kids to
harvard
barack obama sent one of his so did
former new york governor elliot spitzer
the all-time record though must go to
former vice president al gore
al gore sent four imagine that
four kids in a row to harvard what are
the odds of that occurring in nature
well statistically it's about as likely
as getting hit by lightning every single
day for a year
and yet somehow the gore family pulled
it off congratulations gore family
andrew cuomo the sitting governor of new
york sent one of his kids to harvard but
the other two went to brown
that's also an ivy league university
that your kids could never get into
brown is as they say highly selective at
least for the children of
non-politicians
but for pure 200 proof exclusivity
nothing beats stanford university
outside san francisco
you could live your entire life in this
country and never meet a single person
who went to stanford
it's that rarified and yet here's the
amazing part
hillary clinton's daughter breezed right
in
how did chelsea do that was it her
formidable brain power
well you can check out her twitter feed
and judge for yourself
now there's a chance that chelsea is
intentionally misleading us
it's possible that her entire public
persona is a kind of performance art
a subversive borat style parody of
mindless lifestyle liberalism
if that's the case chelsea clinton is
utterly brilliant
she's the jonathan swift of our time but
it's also possible
that chelsea isn't joking at all it's
possible indeed it's even probable
that she is every bit as dull and
self-serious as she appears to be
in that case not only is chelsea clinton
profoundly sub-brilliant
you've got to wonder how she holds a
paying job how did someone like that get
into stanford
you might have the same question about
some of the kids at georgetown
university in washington dc
georgetown's alumni magazine is
available online so next time you've got
a second free
take a look you'll recognize many of the
names inside biden
pelosi kennedy these are the children of
famous democratic politicians
are they impressive hardwicking kids who
deserve to be at one of this country's
most prestigious universities
possibly maybe some of them maybe not
doesn't matter
in fact it's irrelevant they're the
offspring of prominent democrats that's
the point and that's why they're at
georgetown
so how does this happen what happens
because our meritocracy
is a sham it's fake they tell you that
only the most accomplished students get
into these schools
but they're lying their friends kids get
first dibs
fellow members of their social circle
kids whose families can help them down
the road
the children of sympathetic politicians
are an obvious priority for admissions
officers
these are the same politicians who
funnel billions in tax dollars
to colleges and universities every year
so letting a senator's kid into harvard
is just smart business
the quid pro quo is obvious it's a kind
of unregulated lobbying
remember the varsity blues scandal in
california where a group of
socially anxious soccer moms tried to
game the college admission system
well this is far more corrupt than that
except that nobody's going to prison for
it
so how many chris cuomo's get into yale
every year it'd be nice to know but we
don't know
like almost everything about higher
education it's opaque
prestigious schools can pretend that
they admit only the most qualified
applicants
because nobody can prove otherwise the
real admissions numbers are secret
they're hidden from public view
even though we pay for those schools
because all of them take massive amounts
in tax dollars elite colleges are like
public companies that lie about their
balance sheets
they're cooking the books to defraud
shareholders
in this case the shareholders are the
entire country
a handful of elite schools form the
gateway to success in america
if you go to harvard you're all but
guaranteed to make more money over the
course of your life
than someone who didn't go to harvard
it's that simple
and so when you rig the admissions
system what you're really rigging
is american society you're creating an
impenetrable class system
for your own benefit and that's exactly
what they're doing you often hear
progressives say that they worry about
income inequality
they don't mean it at all how do you
know they don't mean it
because if the left really cared about
the stratification of american society
they would make college admissions
transparent they'd force
stanford for example to open the books
and show the rest of us
how exactly they're assembling this
year's freshman class
that's what they do and yet democrats in
congress
haven't done that and won't do that they
seem strangely incurious
about how the process works like they
don't really want to know all the
details
in fact they already know precisely how
the admissions game works
and they strongly approve why wouldn't
they approve their kids are benefiting
from it